these guys didn't even try to run the
football today you know we didn't expect
that to happen we didn't think they
would just totally abandon the running
game and uh
we had a real nice plan if they're going
to run it
so
we have to be able to adapt better
to make sure that we can we can turn it
around faster you know
it's easy to admit you got out coached
on a day when you got a new extension i
guess
pete carroll congratulations on the
extension but you guessed wrong right
and that's one of the great
aspects of football as a defense
can you predict what the offense is
going to do and how do you premise your
game plan and they premised it on the
bills trying to run which because they
had success last week i guess chris to a
certain extent running the ball against
the patriots the seahawks concluded that
they would go run heavy again that
they'd flex their muscle and
the the bills set them up
that's one of the things i love about
football every game plan is different
for the good coaches every snowflake is
unique and the bill's found a way to
not run all over the seahawks but pass
all over the seahawks and josh allen
gets re-established as i wouldn't quite
say an mvp candidate yet but he's on the
fringes again right russell wilson took
a shot
to his mvp candidacy not just the loss
but also four turnovers are you kidding
me four turnovers for russell wilson
yesterday but it's all a product of the
pressure they put on and that's what
coach sean mcdermott told me after the
game they just got after him they put as
much pressure as they could on him and
they trusted that it would either result
in sacks or mistakes by russell wilson
and oh it resulted in both well you know
these guys are gonna both of these guys
russell wilson josh allen they're gonna
have a game like this every now and then
i mean when when the game is all about
just the quarterback and hey quarterback
we're not really good at anything so you
guys have to do everything
you know that's a lot it's you know tony
dungy coach dungy brought it up last
night they're just at too much asked of
one guy all the time to where yeah he
just has a little bit of an off day
or one gets a little unlucky and all of
a sudden the game snowballs out of
control we haven't seen that from
seattle you know and russell wilson very
often but the two losses that's the one
thing they got in common you know is the
fact that russell was a little careless
with the football certainly
but you know they ask a lot of them and
you got to be able to kind of take the
ebb and flow of that to a degree now
back to like pete carroll i mean pete
carroll couldn't have expected them to
just run the ball or be run heavy i'm
guessing he meant like i just thought
they would run it more
but why would they you know first off
they ran it against new england last
week because new england has no
defensive tackles seattle's defense
stinks but the only good thing they're
good at is stopping the run
and buffalo's like wait yeah you're kind
of good at stopping the run you're the
worst we've ever seen in stopping the
pass so we are going to drop back and
throw the ball every freaking play and
yes man did josh allen and company make
so many plays in the pass game and this
is what's scary about the seattle
seahawks you know
it really is
you know they get they got a team that
can really throw the ball and protect
just enough to where they can't
man-to-man or play or cover anybody down
the field and josh allen and the bills
just
absolutely assaulted them with the pass
game all day long
and good for josh allen and company
getting back on the on the right track
and they got out to the big lead and
then the seahawks tried to make it
interesting they cut it down to seven
points
before the bills put the pedal back to
the metal with a couple of touchdowns
and essentially put it away and you know
that's one of the one of the detriments
not having your fans present because if
the bills had been up 41 41.
what was it 20 the worst of it was 24 7.
that that's it it's lights out it's
night night because the crowd is not
going to let you get back into it it got
to 27 to 10 also but uh you know you got
to get the seahawks credit they never
quit they never stop but yesterday was
just one of those days where it just
wasn't going to matter josh allen was
spectacular josh allen
had that that that different kind of
motivation that comes from
a personal tragedy his grandmother
passed on saturday
mcdermott told me after the game that he
he said he gave josh the option to not
play he said he wanted to play he was
able to compartmentalize that was the
key word that mcdermott used set it
aside focus on football and and then
very emotional after the game in the
locker room and uh taking care of family
business now but but alan wanted to play
and he played incredibly well and it was
their best game
arguably since the win over the rams
although they they let the rams back
into that one that was one of those wow
josh allen's an mvp i mean the first
four weeks every week it was wow wow wow
wow yeah and then they they got punched
in the mouth by the titans that brought
them back down to earth then they lose
to the chiefs and that that kind of
cemented the fact that there's a gap
between them and the best teams in the
afc and they've been kind of gradually
working their way out of that hole
yesterday was when they stuck their head
out and looked around and realized hey
you know what maybe we can play with the
best teams in the league yeah well i i
think there's some things to be learned
i mean obviously hey tennessee
because they they caught them you know
they were on an off night buffalo it
just wasn't their best football it
wasn't as bad as what the score was made
out to be and then again you know the
chiefs game it was there to be had the
bills were winning in the fourth quarter
of that football game or at least in the
third quarter i believe if i remember
correctly you know a lot of people have
been getting on josh allen the last few
weeks oh you know had the mvp started
now these last four games okay yeah they
played some pretty good teams i mean i i
don't understand the jets yeah well okay
they won
i mean it doesn't matter they won by
they won 18 to 10. it wasn't beautiful
they beat the patriots but no i mean
it's just like we act like you know
you know sometimes with josh allen again
he just never given a free pass it's as
soon as he faltered it was like
everybody's got a show look at the first
four games he was awesome the second
four games even though they went two and
two he was just good not awesome but we
have to find a way to crap on him a
little bit just because he's josh allen
and that's just stupid it just shows you
you know but he's very talented that was
awesome to watch yesterday the bills
yeah i mean
i'm not gonna say they're you know the
best team in the afc but you can see
they're certainly dangerous and they can
sean mcdermott can just get the defense
to be
somewhat respectable after some of those
early season flaws we saw
you know they might have a say in this
one all said and done no doubt about it
now the bills aren't going to be playing
every team or every week a team that
lets you convert third and 72 right uh
which the seahawks will do multiple
times chris yeah well no you're right
they're not gonna they're they're
the bills that was a good matchup for
them yesterday and the fact that yeah
they they're going to be able to throw
the ball at will there's not great great
pass rushers on the seattle seahawks so
josh allen could avoid people extend
plays do all of those type of things but
either way it's still a very dangerous
offense and they'll try to continue to
work on being more balanced with the
offensive run game and all those things
too but they had to throw the ball
yesterday i mean some of those looks
that seattle gives you they're begging
you to throw it you know all the people
at the line of scrimmage i mean josh
allen made a lot of big plays against
all out blitz like hey we're just going
to play no safety in the middle of the
field it's going to be four one on ones
and
you know seattle's not capable of
covering that group that long and you
know between the past interference at
the end of the game with jamal adams the
third and 15 screen pass behind the line
of scrimmage to john brown for a huge
play those were all out cover zero type
blitzes where josh allen brian dabal
caught the seahawks and the perfect
defense and um it was really a really
well thought out game plan and they
attacked and good for them going back to
the like if it ain't broke don't fix it
method why run the ball if you're just
gashing them with 15 and 20 yard passes
all the time don't let them off the hook
and i thought that was kind of cool how
they kept the pressure on them that way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports